were so fool was so full podcast overdue
a toy right here co-host of the year
let's crack it Lisa Esparza right here
sitting in the middle this time nobody
puts her in the corner we have our
special guest we've always a special
yeah they are special always
gwu own other we from New York have a
month-long
the other month I'll skate go map of
West LA boo yeah boy Oh God
we're a long time Gina we started we
thank you see the open mic and a valley
what you can still save me their long
hair man with glasses singlet different
glasses I need to were let go of hockey
sweater all the time I don't know what I
was thinking with that look it was a
penguin the flight snapshot original
hockey fan out in April Wow yeah for the
playoffs not him all year long all year
long he's ready purple and gold dollars
I mean a 1/2 cups the last couple years
and then they're back to losing so it
was risky no they came really close in
93 they were up with one minute left to
go in the game one and one of the Kings
just playing with an illegal stick and
the other team knew because they used to
play with them stick didn't ever like
the curve you can only have a certain
curve of course you could kill someone
when you made it career he managed that
thing go faster yeah swing faster you
can shoot okay so they rose on it in the
old swats yeah I mean everyone cheats in
every sport but what this guy was known
for having a curvier blade
and they waited till he got out on the
ice that's a joke tell me about let me
get runnin Oh fix fix fix fix matter -
oh yeah so they came very close to
winning in 93 but they did not so yeah
hooked to the left
curse of the Gretzky was it be crying
when he came down Lee who was Gretzky is
all the money he was getting oh really
is that what it was about
lotta money yeah when they had him in
the press conference he's all crying oh
no longer cannot put up jockey was all
up in the game sue oh yeah yeah I mean
they had Diane cannon was coming yeah
[Music]
remember John Candy I don't know though
I like kings cause you're the owner
someone I'm a big man they got together
and they bought a football team in
Canada was the owner total uh party
animal a Gordon Gecko thief really took
the Kings into bankruptcy because really
he would go to Europe and buy coins and
steal him and then he'd sell him here
and so the Kings were built on a phony
Empire really likes Matt yeah so he got
put in the he used to live in the
building I lived in I knew that was a
problem when the Kings owners he was
driving a shitty car like I was driving
a nicer car than the Kings owner no
runner me huh I saw him last night at
the gas station he goes this place is in
the sponsor living a very colorful
building that's on Sunset and San
Vicente there's a gas station and it's
the only thing open on the strip late
night so he goes there to pick up chicks
is there anything creepy look homeless
don't go first of all and we had just
would you go I just snuck in what is
your that Bank cake from Sacramento okay
so shall we do what time we're gonna
show up so we this was gone disappeared
are like like holding a beer - and then
I mean this other dude I'm happy
birthday of Benny really is a birthday
June 11
Gemini right now we we found out a
corner where the gate was you could lift
this one do the Gabriel yeah we wrote in
it was like a little case of a gate can
be read to the gate the city wrong like
the wrong okay I realized these case are
now hold in yeah sudo later is gonna be
a loose one okay walking around so we
left the game with unrest again first
person will see Roger we sit down with
legs open fanny pack we're fine exactly
where I'm gonna say a fighter pegs are
cool now even though they are but he was
wearing one they were not [ __ ] cool
no more man we're not JanSport he was
walking he goes is that Roger II as a
yes your daddy host of it to him and he
landed a laugh
he got off I live in his book like I
don't know you read his book but I have
read half of it but yeah Jerry that book
should be me and more beer there's a
documentary on ron jeremy that i saw a
while ago like he was um he's a
narcoleptic like he just falls asleep
randomly well he goes to the comedy
store late night and I always get so
excited so only chyron January's
watching my set so I'd do all these porn
jokes I'd run to the back of the room
and Ron Jeremy's passed out one [ __ ]
joke that's funnier do that for mobility
he'd like moons over my piano
my piano well I mean I had a friend of
mine who directed like one of his last
horns and he was asleep in his chair and
he [ __ ] his pants so my friend wakes him
up and goes hey do you want to like
start shooting but he probably should
shower first
he's like no I'm good he was doing the
point of a little petite chick right and
then that guy he was like doing it doggy
style
then they were in front and I'm like a
bear giving birth man like little but he
used to be a semi good-looking guy like
when he was like too much [ __ ] huh
not enough vitamins I think guys he took
he took that job for granted though you
know like because you didn't have to I
think a lot of guys realized hey we
should - nice going aside yeah well he
was a teacher code even though this part
of Roger is book
we're like he says that uh you know he
goes man sorry hey nobody Dangerfield
and then what a night he goes we're all
having a big dinner time mentioning
who's there who's there and after the
end hey rod paid for the whole [ __ ]
billion cheap bastard and made him pay
for everything brilliant oyster teeth
right it was mad cuz one of those dudes
that hangs around like just say we're
all we're all gonna go eat but the one
big comedians gonna pay for everything
but he says tip y'all you a tip yeah
please start calling one Sheila's five
you left six
I left seven already [ __ ] right it's
another tip for you big right so he'll
leave [ __ ] I mean that dude you're the
energy Reilly multi-millionaire II I
mean he's literally been in a thousand
plus films yeah but I don't think he's
very good with his money so hopefully
Dante get someone account about to you
yeah in Rebecca we're both here that's
right bro yeah that was the wrong time
he's gotta be said like hit when I first
met doctor that kind of comedian he was
doing Miller ice commercials yeah it's
been a while yeah he was coming out of a
war miller eyes with a little jacket
Athene's to have a thin jacket probably
kept the death he's a Salesman oh yes i
have my family feud with his ex-wife bro
you'll be murdered to our a black woman
yeah well John Tate gave me a lot of
stage time earlier you know when I was
pretty bad comic you always let me plays
Canoga ballroom was just a bowling
bowling alley
so I went to five solid minutes that I
would do in theaters all over the nation
I started at open mics in New York and
also after that after you do open mics
you wanna do real shows you start
barking which is handing out flyers on
the street so I would do that for stage
time bringer shows also that your
company could they do that happen yeah
they do it a lot of comedy clubs in New
York now because they have street teams
that just hand out flyers so they can
get people to come in but it always
appears sketch
gee when you're walking around Times
Square and somebody goes home comedy
club dig it yeah would you pass opposed
to a random Torres huh yeah three right
yeah there shows that started in three
there's a five there's like a happy hour
show there's a lot there's so many
opportunities to get on stage in New
York that it's insane it's just I mean
they're not all quality shows obviously
you're gonna perform at some bars and
restaurants so where people don't even
know there's a show you just pop a mic
in there and then they're like oh I was
just having lunch but I guess this is
happening now a lot of those days yeah
me an early dinner short eastern a
college I would like that yeah yeah we
just the wacky shows the Queen Mary oh
damn you know oh there was a show on the
Queen Mary I know how big that
[ __ ] was honey
absolutely and I heard I heard the
engine room I guess was where a lot of
people got killed uh so if you go in
that room you feel it I don't
necessarily believe in that stuff but in
that room I never felt so sad in my life
really feel it's such a dark energy it's
like the Comedy Store the clone the
comedy machine how we receive and he'll
give you a comedy advice I'd rather
again take care advice from Jerry
Sandusky man that'll pay you good but
you do a lot shows and then like some
crazy store sometimes but then you got a
deal ortho dude we did one show in San
Antonio where will we checked in you
know you got to check he we have here
for alleged late check all right he was
a lazy what the literally give me three
okay three is fine so we he make sure
that we all have bottom floors so he
goes just leave your door open there
your your back door open
wait so uh until the show he went back
to the hotel now we're gonna go to the
doors never cleaned it we gotta get to
be out by tomorrow morning when the maid
comes in and if they held up we're gonna
give me a [ __ ] rule dog yeah yeah he
went at the second so I paid for the
first night and wanted you to sneak back
into the room for your second night he
snuck in there's to it and didn't leave
it alone that sounds like the day of
travel method on the road he also didn't
even he brought his own orange juice to
the diner right yeah but this diner I
think it was one of those ones you see
on the window by salia up north and I'm
taking my coffee eating my pancakes you
know just then this blue Heather he
takes a lot of it I know please Sonny
they like can I orange juice no I'm
gonna be box some people and in here we
put he puts on his cup
the lady goes let me put sit on this
glass and their lady good so you can't
do that here oh I'm such an indie I'm
sorry I forgot I forgot when you run the
road with somebody you never wouldn't
Road with them like yes [ __ ]
from it was so bad good set or hail or
something to drop me off yea medgar says
see you later man but then you're with
his food in the car yeah like
day-trading while he was driving so he
had like the stock like the pages of the
newspaper open he's worth like bucks any
car more like he was like like a guy who
got fired from that bus or a bad man
guys working the road to car tags back
but he'll have a full map he's making
deals caught his dogs great ever I did a
scandalous cake with that dude in
Arizona
and there was two incidents one was
where he calls his girl from Craigslist
and I guess he was older than he
appeared and the girl asked for another
drink and then she asked for another
drink and he wouldn't borrow another
drink and she's all later did lose my
number
we've all been there the second one well
that's painful we thought that we were
on the on the show with that he needed
help because the cops are here and this
fool wrote a bad check to a prostitute
the prostitute went crazy in his room
yeah there's two prostitutes they both
got arrested the pip came out and then
that fool was in handcuffs and then he
let him go but she write a check do
prostitutes take checks look like
tweakers dude only Chico California ha
so we picked him up on the side of the
road with the briefcase scams
yeah man was crazy like I got paid like
I got paid good but that letter shows
but he got mad one time because I'm they
gave me the chair for some reason oh I
thought I was in charge the talent and
it was like four eight no seven G's
right you know you know I agreed to get
whatever I didn't complain when I saw
her you know you okay like what $200 but
whole week with like 15 a week for the
we flew me put me hotels San Francisco
you know you want to see that it's not
freaky now we're all abroad school you
know Z you know but you got you got like
less and less at every show again I four
here 3,000 there 2000 it was a clear
like 17,000 dollars a week because he
tries to undercut naca yeah
oh my god I got booked by another guy
named um Terry Neal
Gazza bro
he undercut Andy another gig and up in
Boise Idaho some college gig oh and then
I said I took up to Barry of course I'll
do it man
but then any good boy you gonna take
that game out of the book you're there
for each other put me there for less for
$200 I mean what this guy still you know
what are we gonna give you a way more
but we can match hit man or give me more
I'll go with you yeah no problem
that's the hard works oh my god scam
let's move on him then there's canvas
well you know you call whoever would
have called me first I what I said yes
to the contract for that's good
damn they were happen to you all the
time has to be different you were to get
you the gig and then let the hose looks
at you goes for the main kind of
primordial you know what a show host um
no that's never happened but I've had
guys be like hey so I got this gig for
you but there's only one hotel room so
we're gonna have to share those I was
always like deuces raping I'm out I'm
gonna fall for that one okay well they
worked there's definitely shady Booker's
on the on the on the East Coast a lot
there was a guy in Boston who we got to
the point he didn't pay me for six
months it got to the point where I had
to have like one of my boys call him and
be like if we need to make a trip to
Boston we will make a trip to Boston so
I suggest you put that check in the mail
and so finally he paid me but it took
six months it was so bad like there's me
everywhere you got those Booker's that
are shady that undercut you that run
away from paying you money all the time
I'm assuming you guys have been going
through that for years yeah Jodie's in
Arizona and I got my money and Joe Diaz
got their money and we all went to the
ATM and we want to get food but
mother Martinez and Lydia Nicole two
female comedians they haven't got their
money and they hit us up yeah I got your
buddy yeah they give it to out to a show
well they haven't paid us and he goes
all right you guys with who you get with
we're here with some dudes on the show
and I'm that little that featherweight
boxing boxing champ Michael carbajal
yeah all right so yeah I'm gonna do well
here's a number and this is a hotel room
he's that he's in a different number
fooled Michael Carbajal growing he know
tyson bro ain't no the Ruiz junior
champion wait he's [ __ ] 108 you know
so he went over there brilliant I'm
banging the door and all his homies went
in there
Oh J style bro it and they made
everybody pay everybody would be good in
the comedy world is gonna be living in
somebody's guest house right now in that
ironic like most comics so there we go
Andy Kern's headlines so that's my goal
man to like be kind of popular that what
a my friend because I'm
multi-millionaire and I retire his home
guy that wealthy at one point is now
penniless what the [ __ ]
buy the cars the homes then car then
when you get so rich when you stubby
like making this case you start buying
like dinosaur bones or who has I don't
even know for castles that you know I
don't know that couldn't name one I know
I want to buy a castle on Ithaca my
nights doesn't have a moat I want to
know these things I wanna buy a castle
be like Andy Kern and
[ __ ] gargoyles day brother brother is
like held in a secret room no weird show
with that same guy had now my wave here
to show up and I waited there was like
this dusty food like something for like
a baby powder in his head right and now
and he was like just like he just woke
up and literally somebody put baby
powder on him and he's male baby powder
and I'm waiting and instead of start to
show and I see the same guy go up well
you ready Phillipe it yeah ready for
what the show
who are you he goes up there and starts
the show and does the same act like his
brother but better funnier oh no he's
doing better either better it's like an
any Kaufman almost weird man the same
act on his brother the same act so he
can do so and he's not there good like
the gallery I should do that I have an
identical twin sister I should do that
one day as a trainer I should right we
got to work together more the morning
radio obviously ping you go be charming
we're just done girl that's a budge I
started in LA which is like the worst
place to start just every yeah
whatsoever I'm like le accident I mean I
started at The Comedy Store but it was
so wild back then I hear probably 99 or
2000 but it was very dark energy there
so I wasn't ready for it so I just
didn't open mics and then came back
about 2010 to try to get in there so
1999 that was like um just do a lot of
the older comments they're often
eighties huh yeah and they were bummed
out because they weren't working anymore
and you know it's like if you if your
last movie you were in was like bachelor
party with Tom Hanks and you know 82
they're pretty better and then you know
Brian diamond dude I didn't want to say
is that funny man
he has Pat buck was named the man you
know pepper I know pepper berry diamond
right now very very diamond please Pat
buckles on Seinfeld as a male comic
though named Pat book oh okay the pepper
cause told me was that um they mentioned
there was a part in a 10-fold they
mentioned a manager but her name was not
Pat buckles so they should told Jerry
once and she stopped him at a party you
could just hit my name Pat buckles so
they're a favor got buried diamond and
his card your name with Pat book oh no
way that wasn't been cool for Pat though
unless the manager was crappy the show I
I have not seen that episode so I just
the old carvings at the Commodore the
year you're talking about like that I
smell probably their everyday a dish
from character bring his dog to
performance sweats the TARDIS from oh
dude yeah there was a lot of Lyle dude
dude strange acts that were still and
the open mic on the belly room will run
by by Chewie yeah and there's no some
horrible open my spoon let people woke
up this morning and took a flight and if
I do the open mic I mean when shoe is
running the open mic I think he was
trying to get new customers for his side
business everyone say it was snowing a
lot when Chewie was out there I showed
up with people and they were all you go
to with him only PJ PJ was you I did I
got father party at his house for a five
nights straight yeah it is funny because
everybody in that house was getting up
and doing a normal day and I was just
saying in the cows that the Terminator
just waiting know who that dude wasn't a
man what a me baby yeah baby West yeah
yeah whose
he's got severe cerebral palsy like
severe and of course the comedy saw a
couple years ago had a boxing tournament
and Davey was in it
it was Davey against PJ yeah so barely
won hard yeah because he does his we're
like John wick matrix PJs short arm so
he couldn't quite reach him wow what a
bodybuilder back in Washington something
happy no you know I don't know a day
school story I'm not sure if I wanted to
know yeah but you know it was a dark
energy back yet we saw him I think that
the in Seattle he showed up at that
comical the parlor bar think yeah I
think he had that's where it was from
from Washington but it was just to you
know you have to be ready for the store
otherwise it'll just swallow you whole
and I would even say that today you know
but it's much better you know place you
know it's probably the number one club
in the country but I always suggest to
younger calm which don't go up there
unless you're right go bomb somewhere
else you know bomb somewhere else and
then or do well somewhere else and then
come to get a job doing graphics and
videos and then like you know do it you
could do all that stuff you could get
you could jump into the comedy magic
club cuz they're not doing well with the
graphics right you know you're you're
anywhere else except flappers those guys
are great at flappers number two club in
the country they send you an eight page
contract and then the last page this is
no compensation oh let's just do the
show I'm not the smartest guy in the
world but I get eight
stipulations on sign away your dinner
like you also get no food where I don't
know I never really vibed with Dave and
Barbara but I respect them for starting
a club out of a Mexican restaurant and
keeping it going is that the story by
flappers yeah macaroni grill if
something wasn't it oh yeah I thought it
was like an Italian or Mexico's Macaroni
Grill for a while and it failed and then
so they came in swooped in and took over
the space I mean I'll give them that I
think he was me what were the comments
originally at the house they had they
had a place out in Clermont
yeah uncle clashes strip mall and then
in a strip mall that's a small club no
it's it's still it's called flappers too
but it's clear I think it's close oh is
it no yeah but what did they start down
buckle plays comedy contest all right
yes yeah around 8:00
I will what are you talking about I did
as a waitress and I was like oh I was
like all these people at this bringer
show the customers are pretty good like
they all play and he was like oh oh I'll
do a comedy show with somebody that's
relate to know and I'm and I was in the
Pasadena and then when I got there with
corporate money there's not open mic I
don't want to point the comma there but
no dude recording everyone say he's the
comedian it's open mic is my club well I
think they teach comedy if I pursue
which is completely insane anybody
listening right now you wanna know
do comedy by the best Rudi Moreno's
comedy class if looking up or if you
have a daughter if you have a daughter
or a son who's getting bullied at school
they want you to know how to get some
good jokes at kids go to comedy camp The
Laugh Factory
um this Saturday they're gonna have
editions they're starting this Saturday
yesterday last week but you could get
all the information laughs Roger Cobb
and Jim I saw that man if you blow up
he'll manage you forever
you got a distorted body he's banished
so many people throughout the years
right because he was Aisha Tyler's
manager yeah I love him so much that I
would have jumped into the coffin with
him that there was wrong he got cremated
can you imagine that taking that order
more coal yeah we need a bigger slab we
need more fire I'm going without his
request do you mean I'm not sure on that
one but it was a great dude why don't
you cremate it red
well I'm announcing here I want to be
cremated we will do ashes spread it
apart Morro Bay Bay okay when I first
met you or started without the bus cafe
in the valley oh yeah yeah that well
that was a speed freak recovery bar yeah
so you imagine the crowd like it was and
they you know they replaced their
addiction with cigarettes so if you
didn't get it on the first minute oh it
was a great time yeah yeah because there
was like a guesthouse in the back where
they would set up shop and smoke and
drink and probably still do speed but
Alice Cooper's daughter worked behind
the bar so that was kind of cool
like meet her Alicia Cooper oh yeah Wow
daughter he he really burned her hello
Jeana you and I we had a television do
the same dear oh we did yeah I mean you
get regressors Angela Johnson and they
were searching for Latinos they were
that one picked
oh yeah that one got pictures to
everything not ethnic enough [ __ ] a good
part of deal right with the deccan James
yeah with CBS that was a that was a
crazy time it was a it was a cool thing
he is a cool guy but how far did you go
with it we've already wrote the script
we actually got to the script writing
and then they just they can the whole
thing they didn't I I didn't like the
script you sure we didn't shoot it no I
don't know what's harder like shooting
it and they're not getting it or not
shooting it at all but still not getting
it they both suck writing it and not
getting it and having the penalties
money for free penalty fear they say no
there's a penalty if they don't shoot it
as a pilot should I pay it was called I
was mad shoot or pay put its gotta put
attention in mind it's a good sight a
necklace I give them our ages been to
another that's we Peters out writer that
one that was it we had Peter Murrieta
and I know Peter Peters are gonna do
Bobby Bowman are we bowling by Bowman
with with um my name is Rowan some king
of the hill and Peter Weir thought with
Stella and Wizards of Waverly yeah did
you also do one day at a time or no yeah
but he didn't do it
thank you brother know who he was but he
was with the same guy who was doing his
show now Kevin him and Angela Johnson
was doing her show somewhere I don't
remember hers i think hers might have
been like was it ABC's it was NEC yeah
then it was very busy then there was a
Dominican were never me but Vlad yeah
his was with Fox I believe it was either
yeah I think it was Fox it has get made
the I think they filmed the pilot or
that one yeah how about Joe Diaz this
year I didn't hear anything coming out
with us I hate they were writing it but
I don't know I think cried or tears I
don't know if they got approved to write
it but I don't know what happened
better be on late night case I would be
interested what my Nora would be we
should nobody fall they picked the fall
things in me he's not a crazy life so I
would that would be one I'd be worse
doing a production company and now with
Ben dealer production company we're
trying to picture one race but I've been
watching a lot of billboards for those
shoulders for consideration
maybe I'm older now maybe I don't watch
TV but never indication already basic
cable basic effects and yeah talk about
Klaus I mean I just got into watching
the show animal kingdom on TNT
it's like Sons of Anarchy meets Point
Break and their four seasons then I'm
like I've never even heard of this show
and it's like really good so I'm in my
last year of Mad Men on Netflix oh we're
so sad it's ending I'm sorry I know I
know we're all late on that show we're
Jon Hamm how many seasons that show yeah
we're in the middle of madman the movie
like that's right at like 12 every row
I've seen them now when I see it now
another remember him Jon Hamm it's kind
of it the same character doc yeah it
just remain only only sounds that your
dog forward I thought yeah she didn't
like our Jon Hamm commentary she was not
happy that's my man
I'm late to the party because I just
started watching it exactly
no I focus I was like I told my
girlfriend I was like yo I just have
watching that show big.little why she
was like you madly like everybody's been
on that the cast is insane there's so
many shows yeah there's like keep up
with my extras I've never seen extra
open mics you know what I think there
was a documentary at one point that was
up it was probably a hood documentary
because I remember getting a DVD from
somebody edit so now it was like it was
something called open mics but it was
about comics that were starting up but
it was shot so ghetto like I tried to
watch no I can't I was doing that sure
what was the name Roger odd no you know
told you Tony
and then this guy shows up oh I would
have killed Tony right and then late
some guy randomly begs to be on the show
right and he gets on the show and then
he films himself and then Stephen was
there Steve was in the audience
oh yeah he's talking interview steve-o
sigma's later he talked to me for a
little while right takes more later he
put all that everything he feels into a
movie and no IMDB he tagged I have
another [ __ ] credit there got paid
she's going to release for that homeboy
it was like for a blog or something
right and he was just like interviewing
it's a movie my buddy just did a film on
his iPhone Mike Herman
so that's that the AVN award tears I
don't know to me to era careful you
don't want to be associated with your
good as far as you know like every like
every guy is like is there a story about
me out there's gotta be one everyone
[Laughter]
that drove Adina made to arrest you if
you're like you you're a woman a female
coming and leaving your own your window
where they're trying to get in there I
rolled my window I was picking you up
Podcast at Joey's house and I was
rolling my window up I rolled it down
just like this much and then he was
talking to me so I wrote a little bit
more and then he went in to come over
get his love he could he rode shotgun
with Kennedy making of Kennedy you know
with man for drunk yeah the best full
charge the whole chart
shoutout to full charge if you'll be
rainy and Caroline next week January 22
or 23
with real Toria Tolley rocky and Lisa
you saw me I don't know I have to call
his counselor today s see if he has
summer school Oh Oh anyway so but now I
have bought a book at a bookstore and
Portland you know like so you go to
these blogs about true crime and I saw
one of Michael
mark Fuhrman write great detective
yeah and and now here and I really hope
this book he wrote a bunch of book after
the og trial and so I bought it I read
it and it goes man this name song is
lastly soft familiar because you don't
meet too many Skakel's and then I
realized then that when I realized I put
two two together because those cables
are related to it with Kennedys it was
about a murder that happened at this in
his private home and Connecticut right
Elijah but allegedly right and this girl
this young girl was killed when she was
16 and the other guy named skater was
like six 18 or 17 years old - but then
it's a retrial him and it's his 40s -
right I just became a headliner so okay
so explain how Skakel and Kennedy are
related well my dad's sisters Ethel
Kennedy okay who younger people are
gonna be like is that she married the
second Kennedy brother that got
assassinated Robert so you know those
are my uncles so and then that
particular cousin you're referencing is
my first cousin what's his name Michael
I believe Michael Mike newspaper Michael
Skakel and there was a very famous trial
was moxy was the name of the girl
well it would say it's it was before OJ
right wasn't it no after it was after
but it's it's an interesting story you
know because if he if he did it and I
really don't know if he did or didn't do
it I was six years old and pled guilty
he was I think 15 at the time he would
have just served two years and
juvenile detention center in prison but
he didn't and then they went after him
when he was an adult and he got
convicted and then it got overturned but
Furman wrote the book he did in that
book well because in for like 20 years
everyone thought it was his brother who
had done it and Mark Furman wrote the
books and no it was the other brother so
and then you know it's a trial and it's
a whole book spurred on the trial
yeah his book I mean Furman was
obviously he's a horrible racist but he
by all accounts was a good detective so
I mean what could detective isn't racist
guys we pose this question yeah
the non racist detectives are working
the desk just even deep man he talked to
people about he touched your
neighborhood all these kids were omitted
to ignore they're loud and all that time
you talk to other kids and let me talk
to it like a bunch of people I gave it
like of that kid would've uh barely
pushed someone they even spoke to that
person well the alibi he came up was not
the greatest it said that you know
there's rumors that they found DNA on
the body so he came up with some
scenario where he was jacking off in the
tree where the body was found
you gotta give him points for that
jackoff in a tree but everyone asked me
about the alibi I'm like what do you
think I was in the tree won't want to
come on the dog it was the Sophie's
Choice where'd I put it
you've all been cleared though it's yeah
it's gonna go on forever and he's not
incarcerated no sounds you just feel bad
for the mom cuz she used to relive this
for 4050 years now it's coming upon and
you know you really do feel bad for her
so and on that note I'll be opening up
for Jeremy
no those hats huh why he came up to me
when I did the special rice Little
Britain Shaba the special yeah I mean
but I mean Brendan works hard I'll give
him that
like I don't know him very well you hope
not yeah I mean he's trying like you
know for someone who's done comedy you
know what under a couple years Jeremy
Piven start Tom's coming a while bagging
that often ain't started you know I
think he just you know he got me to it
out of you know this TV show and you
know he's like that's what I don't like
about stand-up everyone thinks they can
do it yeah you know whether it be
football players or you know me two guys
you know and then Jeremy if Heaven came
up to me once at the Comedy Store after
he bombed for 15 minutes and he said hey
man I think I got this I'm sure he's a
nice guy but it's like you know this
comics out there working 20 years longer
who don't have it you know and they're
funny so you know but I'll see him at
the Laugh Factory is about I'll lay that
if you live in our land you start it in
our lays not like moving out here from
New York you know I'm just living here
man you can see you started like in 94
and then you meet a comedian I started
like an eighty four eighty nine and then
I hear doing stand-up but you do it
you're working but the amount of [ __ ]
are to do an open mic well yeah I mean
it's hard to get you know into the clubs
if you don't know TV grass so it's just
it's hard to get a TV credit unless you
have States yeah catch-22 yeah yeah so
it's some of the open mics have better
lineups in the comedy clubs you know but
it's just the way it is you know it's
never been easier to get on TV now you
can do your own YouTube stuff er yeah so
that's good but that's also bad because
then everyone can do it like I'm like
New York comics that come out here is
always not enough stage time that's all
I hear from my friends I move out here
there's just not enough cuz you can't
just get into the clothes no really hard
to start like you you would have to how
many times
so you open mic before you even get a
spot at the club you know if you don't
have a name already coming in they don't
already know you if you haven't
established yourself and how do you get
stage time at the regular clubs I've
know the rest of it is bars and
underground clubs you know shows that
they're not gonna find out about on a
trip out here for a week what is it like
starting out here because I know like in
New York because there's so many
different venues you can do comedy at
like what is it like out here do they
have the same little like hole in the
wall spots that you can do to get some
kind of stage time when you start I
thought I don't know I open up an alley
weekly la Express y'all my log yeah yeah
I didn't merge with somebody else
and I was and then I'm no drama no had I
get I can't believe how many are dishes
that magazine had I don't know they're
all [ __ ] oh yeah there's some guys
apartment table rate in my underwear is
in quotes Ollie Weasley the back had
everything man man seeking man women
seeking man all that dog then it had
porn section of the best massage parlors
red bar what what porn star was gonna
headline at though at Bob's classy lady
Bob's managed by John met Keisha was it
cheetahs and so so I saw Opie that's a
comedy it was a shitload man but first
with all the main clubs that fact the
Comedy Store was a long time ago egg B's
ego I'm Pico and there was a big comedy
club on Babur and matura carob alley
cabaret but all these are these people
like all of them had names like people
that were gonna be there already so
they're all your book shows but then you
go to the bar or on the way in the
bottom you see like Chuy's Mexican Grill
okay right on Wednesday right and you
see we're in a bar over signups at 6:00
and then I saw natural fudge and I went
there and
was open mic on Mondays I met Eliza boat
in their junior that a fools there so
yeah that what that was like the only
way to find it back then so those guys
hanging out there with those open
microscope with makers knowing those
guys like some of these guys like later
on they had friends they had like a
little bit of success but they know tell
them about another room so after that
I'm know another room are called Waldo's
comedy stage in a Hollywood it was had a
Hollywood apart Hollywood and they paid
my 25 bucks so that was cool so there
are I met Johnny Sanchez
and Carlos Oscar and Willie Barcena and
they told me about Latino night and then
all the laughs acting yeah they're not
that I seem more like you know that I
ever seen because I felt only me me and
Freddy solo yeah cuz they didn't really
play that they're wrong so they
purchased our Latino night so every
Monday we had a pact that's you know
night on Mondays and he would do Spanish
right he would do a second show in
Spanish or something yeah do you do
yourself in Spanish it yesterday roast
I'm so nervous I'm ready to a show to do
it in Spanish and I'm like I don't know
if I can I've never done my set in
spanish you speak spanish i do it's
really like good conversational and boy
did something I let people know because
I don't want to speaking all the time
something I'm not really good I can't no
I can't you can't
no I may I could have a good my
conversation is only good with Mexicans
who didn't graduate high school like
those guys where are these guys
accommodation with them but people are
educated and we're on Telemundo
you know who don't know like me soft man
so how would you say how did it feel
we're practicing the Spanish this well
yeah yeah probably like six like you
know I can't they're like it myself cuz
I stumbled last night and I forgot some
words if I get nervous I stutter in
Spanish so it's 38 you're right at 38
minutes
I stumbled and I said one English word
so that kind of threw me off so that if
they're like yeah so without riot then I
did like 55 oh dang that's so that's so
brave man I'd be afraid to do five I
would be so nervous my pretty sure the
next one will be better because if I
have them like back-to-back like if I do
one Wednesday one through my Friday
Saturday I'm through it by Saturday
you're like young filling this right now
I'm about to go off the cutting company
that's why these are commonly spot there
on Thursdays this will be accomplished
spot like I try to hit up all the mics
man like anywhere up and in anywhere I
got to do comedy words down fluffy so
which I compete you know these Kim who
goes up the most part about their 15 or
Tamra but there were some of they were
book shows like I got booked to do when
I come I got a choice 3:00 in the
morning
so after that I want to go do another
show they had Stephen Hague state house
at 7:00 I know some other show at 10:00
and finish it up at the open mic at
midnight after that fact
I think the hardest thing in LA those
you have to have a car yeah oh yeah
absolutely I don't know how people do
rule there's no common spot there to uh
that's not Philippe though got away with
not having a car for what ten years in
LA and he made it to his spots now he
had fans not gonna make it he had
friends with cars and young comics who
needed stage time and he'd throw in five
minutes or whatever you know if when I
turned him any pig ass or whatever but
he did a lot on the bus trains though I
know but whenever I get too [ __ ] up
and like talking [ __ ] on the way home
we'll give you a ride but it won't give
me a ride away bro you're wasting your
time bro no I wanna add a spot at the
Laugh Factory and APA fifteen over the
first guy going up well soon de are we
hosting a clean shot yeah and now she
hooked it up so then after that I had a
spot at nine
no ten o'clock or the first part at the
Long Beach laughs
so I would walk from there to Fairfax
cast that bus and get off on Hollywood
and they take that [ __ ] train all the
way to Long Beach and yeah and then I do
that spot there and I take that train
back to the Laugh Factory to go up at
12:45 a.m. with Bryan host when Tiffany
had raced up the hottest show at balls
Wow host we're closing Tiffany going
second and me going first so that I
would do three spots I think I got a big
fat picture one time from doing like
three spots on standard a he was hooking
me up yeah yeah and that button but see
like I never got the 10 o'clock spot I
was getting at the midnight but no
matter what matter was just dated her
legs what time thing could went up and
bump like four of us that's cool and I
stood up boy once completed seven hours
he did seven hours oh what's he trying
to beat Chappelle I was after it was
like a few months F know it she spelled
it in April and then they were always
New Year's New Year's Day night this is
the night of New Year's Day that must
have been fun and then but the funny
thing was we left yeah we're gonna go
that's what I was dirty what he started
doing that thing with the straw when I
what started going on I was like well we
should just go now he's just playing
around so but then you talked to Claire
the manager next day Claire and she said
Philippe if you just stayed I would have
put you up it was like 7:00 in the
morning
so what could possibly happen man
everybody everybody who pardon our
streets you know all the tourists they
don't know that you can't be enough
against us after 2:00 a.m. you know cars
tornado valets on the card in the
morning they just stopped through their
keys in the trash or is the keys open
right there with the little old door
open when they put the keys they have to
grab you
keys and figure out where the garage is
where would you go get your car that's
insane
I would have had a heart attack that
what happened Bubba the greatest I've
been bumped by Chappelle a lot at the
store but I you know I get it so you're
gonna get bumped by someone it's yeah
I'll take it from now nice man I mean it
sound like we're all [ __ ] we want to
go up as much as we can you know there's
a hierarchy the second day well can I go
okay go I'll just be taking my check
I'll leave right my mom is here so yeah
leaving your mom for being a star yeah I
understand like guys have a first
would've been the girlfriend their mom
and all that and then a bomb or someone
not the brother of the realize that
they're like 10 dude here we're way way
funnier than I said yeah I lost every
girlfriend I've ever had at
accommodation other comics you know the
economy stores like the bar in Star Wars
it's just like every [ __ ] free oh we
love her all let's go in the main room I
actually care for up there it's always a
bad idea I'm feeling more nervous when
people come to see me like when my
husband comes or like my family will
come to see me I'm like please just
don't
it's worse now if something goes wrong I
feel terrible [ __ ] that you're watching
this when people ask for advice he
always tells people go to as many open
mics as you can and don't bring anybody
you know yeah with you cuz it motherf er
nervous yeah because then you have to
see that person after you bomb or those
people after you bomb horribly and
you're going to bomb horribly in your
purse the first couple of years you're
going to bomb a lot oh yeah but nothing
about getting paid yeah absolutely
you made a guy
- some people are you talking to
what's-her-name right Gracie Gracie
would you say about the commas in the
909 she just I don't know about the 909
she's just saying general the people
she's hanging around with her just
always concerned about how much it
everything pays how much to pay is how
much it pays even if they don't have a
lot of experience these cameras never
even these comments never even even past
the six whole five yeah but they're
making a living in that area yeah that's
the one thing about Latino rooms over
there okay oh yeah and then dancing
afterward oh I've been in those rooms
before he's the one the guy over at
tortillas right yeah i bond for like 30
minutes and it's dead silence and
they're like hey they loved you they
don't like you they'll let you know
anything oh then they like yeah that's
great and I had a red car at the time he
said you got to get out of here now I'm
like I thought you just said they like
was like this is a krip neighborhood
I'll see you later Laurie they don't
like time of blood that girl did not
like Jose were they gonna participate
with a comedian let's bring a girl here
do magic no no that [ __ ] that one dude
huh
dude there with the New York Hat he was
at the comedy magic club for a while -
and it was Jeffrey something Jeffers
deal ya know somebody's got me this man
you came with the girl one time two
tortillas what happened he bombed so bad
that he was blaming the crowd and then
uh you you you weren't around right
there well you took off but Willie's all
saying like on the side going it's not
the crowd bro oh no no no it's a crowd I
can go back up you're not going back
back it up well yeah she was getting
crazy but you you left he didn't they
just left but still argue with the
audience yeah she was [ __ ] this club
they don't know yeah she was all really
late she was all dressed up I didn't go
clubbing after or something but she
could try to get all crazy it wasn't
happening what's her number I like them
crazy after that
the way the Yankees had in a Yankee
Jersey Lee doing stand-up but doing
comedy magic that's great what room is
this
so he bombed that room really made you
strong although I've seen a room where I
start ways to go always have food beer
and there's a lot chase over the last
dude a drug dealers and bikers yeah our
bikers in the hood one room I went to
like I know that half I knew I could
name like to do they were killed by
somebody I grew up with oh sweet I mean
there was like a bunch of drug dealers
that I found out later on which I didn't
know back then but they were rocker they
were out the room with always packed I
mean it was eating it over oh I'm
talking about 40 old guys they're
pretending up by nineteen year olds bro
that's gross I would never do that
what does this guy he brought his boat
you show it off his boat that was about
it was about philosophy and blood over
there there's the guy at the hop
he put a brand new homer and he parked
it right in front of the Ernest Ernest
number bigger this big weasel Michael
Vick's house oh you see madman good
that's a angry bar this guy was the
promoter of the show row at the hop in
Lakewood okay so he would like let's get
with a promoter at the hop in Lakewood
and there was big Ernest and like he
would like to get into dues first so
he'll go up there's a gentleman big a
big ern and he goes up there what's up
everybody welcome to the hop we're gonna
have a comedy show
they went to choose your host Willie
Barcena
then will it go up it he'll get off now
he thought he was like Russell Simmons
or something he had he was here a Harley
Davidson and he parked it right in front
of the place where I could see it
so it was all about showing off what you
can grow but that was not the only show
he had he would be promoter I just saw
Russell Simmons yesterday he was sending
his body to with Roger at the
cryotherapy place I go said you tried to
cut in front moved to Malaysia there are
these charges against him frozen chamber
oh that one that oh yeah yeah ja he's
the one that actually got me and like
you know have you what have you noticed
that's different
my dick shrinks a lot I'm holding it
minus 200 degrees so how do you not get
hypothermia frostbite or something yeah
you are beanie it looks like a rubber on
my head he's my pet so big very few
beanies fit me and you were like shorts
and the special socks your feet ill
froze it's good if you have like
inflammation or something to wake you up
you know so you know pretty awake you
know Joe's doing it it's got a bigger
dose Daymond you go out today and i7
like - 7 degrees outside and then
running back into your apartment
go do comedy in Winnipeg you can have
that experience
nobody coldest spot has been by the
Kansas no probably Green Bay you went to
Green Bay in February oh that's right I
think it was like making Chicago that's
coming I did Chicago for New Year's and
who don't y'all can keep this yeah whoo
there was Toby Hicks and that foot was
cold Matt well what do you say bro out
is too cold
Winnipeg it was minus 20
with no end shell was just a straight
there was a guy outside in his shorts
and flip-flops and he looks at me goes
where you from I'm like oh I'm from LA
just looks like
because I was bundled up I had like
three sweats on me through that jacket
so I'm checking me and man I'm the only
one waiting thermals a scarf they're
just a beard or even their stalks like
how do you have a target - 20 and these
dogs to a podcast yeah yeah it's called
inappropriate number one right it was
and then I got kicked off the charts for
a music violation and I can't get back
on why what happened I had the same song
you know it's just a theme song my
buddy's 80s metal band did and I think a
roast battle comic that didn't like me
yeah but I have the permission no it's
so because I was number eight oh you
know it hasn't gone back up because of
that yeah like we don't manipulate the
charts I'm like I'm not asking you to
put me how to Rogen I just want where I
was at and they're like it's very so are
you starting from zero then I almost
want to start over and just you know
switch the name and get a different URL
they're not very helpful
but you know they don't I don't know I
started wondering your podcast one time
and then like halfway through you
thought you're talking about I'm not
manipulating the numbers yeah and then
yeah I was I would make a joke because
people would be like well you're kind of
an unknown comic or whatever why did you
build a GRE a lot of times right no no I
don't you know he asked me wants to do
it I'm like oh my god I'm in I'm finally
on I'm gonna get to go on and hike and I
think he was you know I maybe he was
tired that night I don't think he
remembered asking me so I know he hates
if you ask to be on right yeah I don't
know how to like hey Joe remember what I
thought the first time when he asked me
one time
thankfully Pam I have you on my show all
right and then you gonna give me your
number
forget my number and then like I don't
know a year or I know eight months
passed by I saw him again at the
cemetery show and I give that fool a big
ass blunt like I always do
and then we start smoking it and you go
yeah we'll have you on all right so then
I will promoting my HBO special
so I [ __ ] up at I [ __ ] up cuz your
tears are the night tax no like Dex [ __ ]
no no I mean the real [ __ ] texted me
[ __ ]
don't even [ __ ] bastard either Thank
You channel number and I'll [ __ ] call
you back
well my glasses so oh so Jeb yeah brah
George your throat yeah even have you
are I'm gonna have you on so I like Tex
mmm of the way he's no special right so
like no the only one but then um I said
I'm not sure yeah I mean he'll be
inviting me to do shows with him at the
ice house with the rest but I was never
around cause I'm always how to tell him
I don't know but I'm I told him I I
wanna tell him but but then I'm not sure
we were off for like four and a half
hours yeah Wow oh he's such a good
interviewer like then we play pool for
two hours why visit yeah well whatever
dinner I thought I went or yeah what are
we gonna have gym sauna like 10
different cars but like you know shows
you what hard work at you like he should
motivate all of us he was at one point
unknown and yeah I was the most known
comic in the world or arguably you know
what on your podcast do you think the
Tommy episode there was a two-parter
right yeah I mean one I think that's
probably the one that the one that
really kind of direct a lot of notice
yeah
Tommy was did I listen to those well he
was probably the most controversial
figure in LA comedy was the racist
talent coordinator at the store
or you know he says he wasn't you give
him the opportunity to speak his piece
well I heard he had asked Marin you talk
a lot
oh I just hit record yeah that's um one
question yeah what was my and then two
hours later I came in and just wasn't
like and then he starts describing this
artist kind of cute
what's your name like a hot young blonde
I guess I was a best-looking guy out
there I can't concentrate with Denzel
Washington looking down on me from the
hotel billboard he had some interesting
views on society and some accounting
methods I think I started with his
partner well yeah I'm done in 98
yeah and I got past it 99 98 he was like
the phone guy and then I think midsized
try it out together a stand-up comedy
one who would you think you were the
hanging around yeah I mean well he told
me they liked me
yeah that's the first time I walked in
he'll put me up sleepy wanna go hell
yeah
and I don't know it's toothpicks on one
out stuff but I got up but that's great
dark dingy talking about I will go up
there was showed up people who liked you
and then others what ever been away from
him night who was this guy that you're
talking about he was the manager of the
Comedy Store for many years but he also
he was there at the right place at the
right time because at the same time
Mitzi was falling out of the day-to-day
he was yeah and he may have been acting
like her and he did such a good
impersonation that he would you can't
even walk tonight yeah when he had a
weird almost like a Harold and Maude
reference but like and she was almost
bedridden at that point and then she
eventually was bedridden before she died
and well the funny thing after the first
one is a guy he'll never come back
hey Tommy if you ever want to come back
let me know so the next day he calls me
wow I'm in the neighborhood
we could finish up when we started oh so
it was done on two different sessions
yeah oh I thought it was like one that
you cut up I had to kick him out on the
first going on - I got it ran out of
tape yeah well almost and then you know
he was then off air he talked me for
another 40 men well she told me to take
money but just don't overdo it
like what Jewish owner is going to tell
you to take he was very political - in
the inside the club and so had his
favorites and then had people he didn't
want there and he would block people and
ban people and you know and then other
people just stayed awake didn't like him
yeah told Rob Schneider once when I was
opening up for him Rob is like hey can I
get in at the store I'm like I'm pretty
sure you can get in and Tommy's I come
on potluck potluck it was yeah this was
when he was working with Edwin probably
yeah so he was one of those dude him on
the marquee it's a sold-out room yeah
telling him to come on with the album
eiger's how did Rob Schneider
Rob I mean four years are opening for
him he never didn't sell out of room not
even one show wasn't the copy machine
god he doesn't even have to really be
funny or huge long was he funny yeah hey
I've never seen his stand-up my bowling
star very young comedian specials yeah
with his Oh bubbles Brown's
tonic just like a ten minute special
two-minute bit on dude he's really funny
after every show he'd go up in this
hotel room and start writing again like
it's a very like oh you could go out at
least married so but you could go out
nice dinners or like mingle with the fan
no he went right up and he had all these
like hundreds of 3x5 cards with jokes
I'm like you don't have to work this
hard he does that's admirable did all
the morning radio even
shows were already sold out so he taught
me a lot about how to even if you're
successful still gonna work on right you
know that's cool so yeah but the Tommy
episodes are the ones I try and get
people listen to because whether you're
an old comic or open mic or you'll I
think gain benefit as to what a maniac
sounds like and he's not the only one in
the comedy world he's not the only
manager who's but I think he stood out
it yes you know when you tell Rob
Schneider come during the amateur hour
I think Andy Sudeikis once someone was
hosting the MTV Awards and they very
nicely came up to the booth and they sat
in the booth like Jabba the Hutt like
you had to go and kiss his ring yeah and
he didn't know who this guy was like now
you know animal birds wanted to do a
spot one I remember that
you know so it was just but then he put
up like boom Shakalaka the homeless over
my car so it was just his personal
favourites that he would come back up
yeah he liked a good leash man yeah the
bush man who beat nor McDonald in Star
Search the original Michael Blackson way
between those two just tense so Bush man
we get spots and you come on stage in a
dashiki and you know he's had like 12
kids by 13 different mamas oh wow he was
a character named bunny beaten or
MacDonald in Star Search like that Susan
I even know that this family copy that
[Laughter]
you know it's the wacky thing Tommy was
operating but luckily they caught on to
his yeah I'm a merabh he had a pet we
were there to see Chappelle
it was [ __ ] past wrong
that's the damn el mágico opened and and
what's in the mechanic okay for Whateley
cannon went up and did five minutes yeah
and the Kennedy five minutes right up el
mágico he did remember he had a stand-up
comedy thing that he did not can the
cannon did a special or yeah yeah while
another and I'm sure Paul went on for an
hour there's a picture of me Tommy
Nick Cannon and now el mágico
I mean that's probably the first time
Tommy was ever pictured with an Hispanic
back to us I saw Tommy play oh yeah did
I say picking lettuce and Salinas but
it's crazy that he was allowed to
operate pretend he was the one that had
to tell Steve Glickman to call Joe Rogan
and telling it was bad now yeah wait Joe
Rogan was bad
oh they banned him for that yeah they
had to pick a size I might add and
Carlos I know Carlos was more famous
than him at that at that time just
before the podcasts and que no I've been
on TV fair fact it was pretty big show
yeah I remember that
you know can you imagine if red band
wasn't taping we never when was the
band's lifted through the camera I don't
know you got probably no fools in right
right van probably had the first [ __ ]
hear that big ass camera yeah so the ban
was lifted a few years ago but he didn't
want to return he didn't return until
Tommy was gone yeah I think well Adam
the I don't want to say new talent
coordinator but he's been there for five
years now he I think reached out to
certain people hey do you want to come
back it's a different vibe I'm here
and then so jokingly pushed that
different vibe there trying to get him
to come back but it works so like you
know Adam if like Rob Schneider came and
probably David Spade would come and
that's chance totally uh you know it's
just a lot more professional atmosphere
I mean Tommy used to pass people gave
him pot I mean I was so desperate to get
passed up there at one point just cuz
you know that stores the store and I
thought what if I just give him a weed
and a new guitar we really stuffed weed
in the guitar and go hey can I get spots
now you should have tried it like I'm
desperate that's like you know you're
not weed in a guitar desperate yeah I'm
gonna call Larry Omaha see if I can go
back Yamaha never Omaha were performing
at some hotel the clarion in [ __ ] San
Diego and it was like an improv little
room and I got a hundred bucks and a
hotel and now fool never here when I
walk it's all weird will you see like
comics walking around after the show cuz
let there are different ages he must've
been fifty bro I was 30 he wears shorts
and I was wearing shorts me like a lover
bro we're too old like we were talking
about the last podcast we were now after
a show and what never go out with him no
more like where we want to take me out
after the show [ __ ] no cuz we look to
odd and when I was hanging around up our
tail and let me know what is the geez
even the George Washington to me so then
we hit all the grandfather bro
oppression you and Martin this week
coming up um I have shows coming up yes
at the Jimmy Kimmel comedy club in Las
Vegas coming up this weekend
congratulations thank you that'll be a
fun time I have a couple of gigs in
Washington's name we'd hit up Edwin Oh
word Oh word
okay thank you for that wink-wink
nudge-nudge okay he's always at that
he's performing he's got a residency one
of the best dudes yeah oh yeah out in
Vegas yeah Edwin San Juan I feel like I
know that
I'm Filipino never that name building a
pool now and oh yeah I said I know I
don't think I've gone that poor have a
protein shake well I think there'll be a
lot of things dumped in that pool after
completion they sound effect like the
black guy from police academy I can only
do one sound oh man that guy you know
double did i posted on white shadow that
freaked me out
Michael yeah man such a good show people
white shadow no what is that
you're gonna Coolidge it's yeah you're
way too young but it's a show about a
white coach who coaches in the ghetto
yeah and he goes a basketball club team
in south and Charlene oh yeah well I
called Carver High School white white
white shadow but I can babe was in it
well they can became famous though yeah
only from like 79 to 81 but it was on
Channel two
damn so no charge and they did but this
is when there was only three networks
yeah but they cover like rape abortion
child abuse gay one guy so it was pretty
groundbreaking time yeah mental illness
I cry every time they do that episode
where the kid with autism tries to make
the team and they just think he's read
you know the players make fun of him for
being [ __ ] and then at the end of
the show they give him the ball and he
makes the shot oh I'm I want to cry to
hearing it tell you if you don't cry you
you don't have a mic Winslow and look I
see you like a side story my quest upon
please Academy he must be like 19 or 20
years old and I like he gave I don't
know what the episode about like mental
illness but then the episode ends with
him in front of the mirror doing all the
impersonation one by one and it's [ __ ]
you just get freaked out about crazy he
looks oh wow yeah man yeah they had a
lot of people who went on to be
it's like the within the one episode
where the player was gay so he goes to
Carver highs cuz he picks from no no no
I'm gay here and then they're playing
pickup on the courts and the other
school comes and all your you know I
mean but on channel two and seventy nine
is around this is like Trailblazer yeah
yeah it really was so and then when I
pursue them the only like Mexican dude
to go home is oh man go go go go go go
his father was that a little Mexican
dude right a little Mexican food and
short and he's like a day laborer he's
going but I'm I guess it's a 70 so they
have a white late day laborers and black
day laborers and one of the daily really
[ __ ] Hightower from police academy
yeah Smith published myth and now he
gets into a fight with go-go's dad and
he hugs his dad like out of the truck so
his dad comes home and takes it on his
son he starts [ __ ] him up and you
know [ __ ] out of him and go was going to
school with bruises and they're making
fun of him and then he died episode ends
with gogo on top of his father and about
to punch him in the face aren't quite I
can't be like you
oh that sounds heavy my routine bro I'll
do it open mic i have cable for the
first time i will come home and I
watched ax know never watch out I think
TV land just been on and I think I'm
[ __ ] white shadow will come on at 3
o'clock and then taxi at 4:00 in the
morning they'll pass out I mean the
episode where the coach takes them to
the golf course I think is the best hour
you know it's kind of a drama comedy but
the racial zingers they were throwing
out like you can't do those today you
know you would never know call a tenant
guy but that's more real bad well the
conversations they're having even if
they're painfully that's more real than
what happened
episode where coach we have hires
although take the whole team to clean
his house or or painted then the black
mayors of principals all so you got
slaves now do you choose the keyless
leave now to be a work what we're
talking about
well I mean never came in a race issue
episode they did a lot of Rachel like
when salami saw Coolidge was wearing
knickers he's like hey Coolidge nice
knickers and cool is like what did you
just call me short play on words that
show chop the shark they thought I was
thinking so fraser-smith was saying you
know it the guy who just keep me just
sorry yeah you say what episode was hot
he was a local DJ guy and those guys
would always see whether there was under
the under the boardwalk I said [ __ ]
Nicky singing I know you didn't like the
showerhead as a microphone under the
ball or what and and they make an album
and they don't know who to play with so
they take it to they take it to a Frazer
thank you you better player man I
playing buddy they play right and then
people are calling in that's the worst
song see you never
and then they finally get one call yeah
my lead these guys are great I want to
stand up Marple we're gonna get a hold
of him then frizzy1 are you serious and
he turns around and one of the guys in
the team pretended to be something that
nice in here these are the more
lighthearted episode thank goodness
because it's conversation was all heavy
about this the rate 1/2 though okay this
year I feel like every show at some
point during my adolescence had a rape
episode or an episode where rape was
insinuated yeah even Edith bunker got
raped
yeah well it was like this I could watch
these shows and you'd be like oh it's
like a raper Stevie Wonder or Cosby
probably whoa he seemed pretty
you have a vagina what we are so let's
finish with you got a rep yeah oh yeah I
have a Jimmy Kimmel coming up I have a
couple of shows in Washington State's I
have a special coming out which will be
fun where it's gonna be coming out on
HBO Latino and it's called easily
offended and that comes out just 16th
and then bump up my prayer towards the
end of the year I will be doing the
Staples Center and the Honda Civic
Center with the guys from the fluffy
tour that's what's up that'll be fun
it'll be a magical venue yes very fun
here in our lair or somewhere else here
in LA
and what's your oh that's yeah and
what's your Instagram my Instagram is at
G Bri on the last name is Bri ll o N and
the website is Gina Brianna net oh I got
a cartoon every Sunday night on Adult
Swim
Tyler the creators the jellies the only
one guy in the show I'm jelly I get paid
to be right time I beat out Tommy for
the job and then you know Comedy Store
this week in a few shows but jellies is
my labor of love
what's your Instagram on your pocket
name it say let me spell my last name
it's at Earl Skakel EA RL SK a ke l and
the podcast is inappropriate Earl and
thought to have everyone in this room on
at some point absolutely what's up fool
general jun 22 2013 2 york Caroline's on
Broadway June 26 imma be at the battle
room at the Comedy Store that shows in
espanol it's in Spanish
June 28th to 30th al Ana California
al Ana California another Georgia I
being the punchline
July 3rd San Diego the comedy panelists
are being Spanish July 5th through the
7th Houston improv July 13 Chicago
Illinois big theater July 26 saw Juanita
Arizona desert diamond casino also if
you live in Kiel in Texas never heard of
a play
but they have a comedy club there now
probably you know why is this probably
funny comedy club there's part instead
of a Radisson I don't know no it's a
comedy club twice it's funny comedy club
they call me oh you're bad mill killing
what is that I should have bought a
comedy just have any curve any
differently to mention that I do a
little podcast coming out - it's called
mess in progress and it will be coming
out next month
like I say no but I would love to have
any of it forever in New York and you
want to come from these definitely hit
me up your you live mostly in New York
and come out here every once in a while
yeah I live out and I'm still based in
New York but I come out here for work
okay so that yeah my podcast check it
out on soundcloud but also we have thank
you very much for everybody came out to
leave those jokes last night in Spanish
thank you which is the Felipe Benji Luis
Martin and myself and we'll be doing be
by those jokes on July night yeah thank
you for the go probably the edible smile
smiles and for the crowd he gave me last
night
E and for that food that gave me that
roller one and um it often in Austin
Texas that a loaded chamber it's um a
dude you were wearing a big bird shirt
that's what he told me to give you a
shout out big boy shirt a big bird
shut up to that loud ass cross and I
borrowed I got kicked out halfway
through the show what they were wrong
loud man there was a loud table yeah
well they were it was a theater so these
guys were sitting up in the side but
that's it that's the kuda there that
were like senior citizens shut up shut
up sir you don't shut up for her you got
to be a jerk like she's in a wheelchair
shut up guys then they challenged they
shouted everybody man
what's up fool tiger by for being here
what's up fool I have some vegan treats
that I bought